this is an html crash course i'm beau
carnes and i'm going to teach you the
basics of html
let's jump right into it you probably
already know that html is used to create
web pages
it stands for hyper text markup language
every website on the internet
uses html and css most also use
javascript in a website html is the
structure
css is the style and javascript is the
functionality
here's a great interactive diagram from
codeanalogies.com
you can see we have the page the
structure styling and functionality
and if we move this slider
so it's like the house so page is like
the house so the structure
or the html is like how many bedrooms
there are how many rooms
the css the styling is like the color
the color of the brick here
and then the functionality what you're
doing like eating is the javascript
you can actually see the html that makes
up any element on a web page
by right clicking an element and then
going to
inspect and this
all this right here is the html
in this crash course we'll mainly
discuss html
afterwards you'll probably want to learn
css and javascript
at the end of this course i'll also show
you how to get your html page online
using hostinger.com to host the website
hostinger provided a grant that made
this course possible
hostinger provides web hosting databases
domains and other services before you
learn how to write html
you have to make sure you have a place
to write the html
a program used to write code or html is
called a code editor
there are a few places you can write
html online without installing anything
such as codepin.io or replit.com
i'll quickly show you how to use codepen
to write html
then i will show you how to install and
use a program on your computer
called visual studio code i'm going to
be using visual studio
code for this course but you can use any
code editor you like
if you already know where you're going
to write your html you can jump right to
the part of the course where i start
teaching html
so if you want to use codepen which is
the easiest way to get started
we can just go to codepen.io and then
click start
coding so you can see there's a place
for html
css and javascript but we're just going
to be doing html in this course
so let me show you an example if i make
a paragraph
and type in hello world
you can see that it appears right down
here
and then it keeps updating automatically
you can see it updated with my mistake
and then i corrected it and then it went
back to the correct way hello world
so you can also just ch move these
this stuff around change the view and
this could make it a little easier to
write the html on this side
and then see the result on this side now
i'll show you visual studio code if you
just
do a search for visual studio code
you can go right in here and then i will
click download
and the button will automatically
download visual studio code for whatever
operating system you're using i'm not
going to show the full
download and install process that should
be pretty self-explanatory
once you get visual studio code opened
it should look something like this
you won't have these recent files here
and also i zoomed in a little bit so
everything's a little bigger on the
screen
but you're gonna wanna click new file
and now i'm just going to go to file
save
and for the title i'm going to type in
index.html
and make sure you are in the directory
you want i already created a directory
called
html course so it's pretty standard to
name
your main file index.html
in fact web browsers will often look for
a file with that exact name
when your website is loading up you can
actually
call your html file anything it could be
called
cats.html or new.html
but it's generally good to stick with
index.html
for your first file okay you got a place
to write the html
let's start writing html in this course
you will learn
html by creating a simple page
i recommend that you type along with me
we'll create a web page
line by line and i'll explain the key
concepts
as i go i'm going to first create an
extremely basic html page
and then i'll explain it
okay html is made up of elements
an element is an individual component of
html
so this right here is an h1
element an element will often have an
opening tag like this and a closing tag
and it will contain everything within
the opening and closing tags
you can see a closing tag often has
a slash right in these angle brackets
right before the name of the tag so this
is an h1 tag
that's opening and closing h1 tag
most elements are container elements
that means they
hold content between the opening and
closing tags
for instance it's this h1 element is
holding the content
hello world but some elements are
standalone
like this one right here and we'll talk
about a few more
later this one right here doctype
doctype html this is what all html files
are going to start with
this is the first element on every html
page it tells the browser to expect
html and what version to use and
this just means to use the newest
version of html
and then we have this html element
so this is the opening tag and this is
the closing tag
and all of this are the contents of the
html
element all page content must be
contained
in these html tags and then we have this
body tag here so here's the opening body
tag and the closing body tag
and here is the contents of the body
the body is going to contain all the
visible
content in a page often above this body
element
within the html element you're going to
have a head element
that is going to contain the page title
and metadata
we'll talk about that much later so
for now let's focus on this the h1 hello
world
the h in h1 stands for headings
so h1 is is an h1 element is used to
define headings
and there's h1 h2 h3 h4 h5 h6
and the one is gonna be the biggest
heading
two is gonna be slightly smaller three
is gonna be smaller still
and so on so let's see what this
looks like in an actual web browser
so i'm going to save this a command s or
control
s or you can go to file save and now i'm
going to
open this in a web browser to do this
to open it i'll just find the file in my
file browser
so here's my folder here's the file i
just created
index.html i'll just double click that
file
and you can see it says hello world
that's the h1 element i just created
let me reposition these windows that's
better now i can see the html code on
this side
and i can see the web browser what the
html is
creating over on the right side so i
told you there are different types of
headings like h1 h2 h3 i'm going to
create another heading
so h2 and i'm going to call this
cat photo app and if i save this
and then i refresh you can see hello
world is really big and then
cat photo app is a little smaller
because it's an h2
element another common type of element
is a
p element a p element is used to create
paragraph text on websites
so i'm going to create a p element
you may have noticed that the code
editor automatically
puts the ending tag when i put the
beginning tag
the code editor is automatically going
to put the ending tag right in here for
us
so that's pretty nice and you may have
also noticed
that the beginning and ending tag can be
on the same line like the h1 elements or
they can be on different lines
like this body element okay so right
within this paragraph tag
i'm going to put click here
to view more cat photos
and if i save this and refresh we can
see the paragraph
paragraph text is the main text on a web
page that people read
okay now i'll talk to you about
commenting comments allow you to leave
messages without affecting the output
displayed to the end user
it's common in pretty much all
programming languages to have comments
it also allows you to make code inactive
for instance if we put this h2
element within a inside a comment then
it wouldn't appear on the page anymore
so let me show you how to add a comment
i'm going to put a lesson sign
exclamation point dash dash
and then the code editor automatically
adds the end of the comment
so here's the beginning of the comment
and here's the end
and whatever's in between these dashes
is the comment
so i'm going to put to do
add link to cat photos
so this will just remind me to do that
later
and now we can remove this h1 tag this
was just an example
because this app is really this website
is actually
a cat photo app we don't need this hello
world here
if i save that you'll see that the hello
world is gone and also the comment
does not appear on the page html5 has
tags that identify different content
areas
these tags make your html easier to read
and also help with search engine
optimization
and accessibility we're going to
identify the main
section of this page by adding a main
element with a main opening tag and
closing tag
so right after the title i'm going to
put main
the code editor automatically puts the
closing tag
i'm going to do control x or command x
to cut it
so i'm going to cut this closing tag and
paste
it right here and this is a good time to
talk about nesting
html elements are often nested within
other html elements
so on this page we have this
body element right here this is the
opening tag
ending tag and inside the body element
is all this stuff right here which is
nested and the body element is actually
nested within the html element
and we have this main element inside and
nested within the main element
is this comment and this paragraph tag
what i'm going to do is
select everything within the main
element and i'm going to hit the tab
key that's going to indent
all of the everything within the main
element
indentation spacing and new lines do not
impact how a browser
renders a page but it can make html
easier to read and the general best
practice
is to indent all nested elements
so you can see this is indented and then
this is
indented and this is indented so every
section
anything that's nested is indented
within the elements that it's nested in
and you can see when i select this you
can see these little dots
those are spaces so though i just
clicked the tab button to indent this it
just added
two spaces before each line so you could
also just use the space bar to indent
those
this page is going to have a few
different sections so we'll indicate the
first section by adding an h3
element with the text cat photos above
the comment
so i'm going to put
h3 cat photos
and if i refresh you'll see that we have
this is the h2
heading and this is the h3 heading it's
just a little smaller
now we're going to make this look a
little cooler by adding an
image so right after this paragraph
i'm going to put an image tag now an
image tag an image element does not have
a closing tag
it only has an opening tag it just has
one tag
most elements have an opening and
closing tag but there are some elements
that
only have a single tag they don't have a
closing tag
but we are going to have to do something
to specify
what the image is that's going to
display
and that's where html attributes come in
html attributes are special words used
inside the opening tag of an element
to control the element's behavior so let
me show you
how to do that in an image element so in
this image element i'm going to put a
space
i'm putting the space before the closing
bracket
and i'm going to put src that stands for
source
the source of the image i'm going to be
equals and then i'm going to put a
website here so it's going to be https
colon slash fcc.i
slash fcc re
relaxing cat
now this is a url of an image that
already exists on the internet
so if i save this and i refresh the page
we see this cute relaxing cat right here
so it's displaying this image and the
source of the image is this url it's
getting the image from that url
so this is the attribute
and attributes are always paired with
values
there's always in the value here is this
the value is always going to be in
quotation marks
attributes are selected from a
predefined set of possible attributes
depending on the element so the src
is specific to an image element and a
few other elements
and depending on the element there'll be
a different list of attributes that can
go along with it
but the values are more variable they're
going to be in quotation marks and they
could be
lots of different things depending on
what applies to the attribute
and we're going to add another attribute
right now so
after this attribute in value
i'm going to put a space and then this
is going to be
an alt attribute so the value of this
alt
is just going is going to be a cute
orange
cat lying on its back
so an alt attribute is basically
a way to describe the picture with text
the text inside an alt attribute is used
for screen readers to improve
accessibility
and it's displayed if the image fails to
load
so you should always use an alt
attribute with every image
now we'll add an anchor element that
will link
to another website an anchor element or
the
a element can is used to create a link
that you click on to go to a different
page or website
so let me show you how to do that it's
just a
for anchor and then we have the opening
and closing tags
but we're going to specify what the
website that we're linking to is
so to specify that we're going to use an
attribute called
href equals and then here's where we're
going to put the website we're linking
to
for this example i'm just going to put
cat photos.com
cat photos.com and then
inside uh so we have this opening tag
and this closing tag
and whatever is in between the opening
and closing tag of an anchor element
is what the text is of the link so i'm
going to put
cat photos so if i save this and i
refresh over here
we can see cat photos and i realize i
forgot to put the https
colon slash slash so we need that this
part
for the links and now if i save this
refresh here if i click on cat photos
this is not a real website it's just an
example website for this so
it just says it cannot be reached but
that's how you create a link
next thing is i'm going to actually put
this link
into this paragraph see how we have the
word cat photos here
i want the link to be right there so i'm
going to
cut this out control or command x
and now i'm going to select this text
cap photos delete that ctrl v to paste
in the link if i save that and then
refresh
we can now see that the link is right in
that sentence it's right on that
paragraph
now you saw when i clicked on this it
just opens right in the same tab
but what if i want to open up into a new
tab well we need another
attribute so right in this anchor tag
i'm going to right after the href
attribute i'm going to press space
and then i'm going to add another
attribute it's going to be the target
attribute target equals underscore blank
now if i refresh as i click here opens
up a new tab
the website still doesn't exist though
since this isn't a real website we're
not actually even going to use it here
i'm going to erase this url here
and just put a hash sign or pound or a
number sign here
this will keep the text as a link but it
will no longer link to anything
it's just a placeholder it's also often
used when changing the behavior of a
link using javascript
so if i just refresh here i click here
it still opens a new tab but it just
loads the same website in that new tab
and we can
turn this image into a link i just have
to put
an anchor tag here there's opening
anchor tag
i'm going to copy the closing tag
i'm going to cut it and put it at the
end and now i'm going to put
href and i'm just going to put
it a placeholder link in here so if i
refresh here if i move my mouse
over the the cat photo you can see it
turns into a pointer
because it's a link now if i click here
you can see nothing really happens
because it's just the placeholder and
it's not opening into a new
it's not opening into a new tab so it
just basically refreshes the page
or really does nothing when i click
there
it's finally time for a new section of
the page so
before the closing of this main element
i'm going to add another
heading an h3 and this is going to say
cat lists and now we're going to learn
how to create
lists in html the first list
is going to be things cat love so let me
add a new paragraph
that says things cats love
and then after this i'm going to add an
unordered list ul this ul
element is an unordered list and you can
see i put the opening and closing tags
on different lines
because in between we're going to put
three list items
the first thing cats love are is catnip
and then another list item is
laser pointers
and the final list item is
lasagna and now i'm going to add
after this list well before i add this
next thing let's check what it looks
like in the browser
so here is the unordered list we see
these bullet points and we see the three
items
after this i'm going to add an image of
one of the things on the list
so put the image tag and then i'll put
the
src the source of this image
instead of linking to a url like the
other image on the page
we're going to link to a file right on
my computer
i'm just going to put lasagna.jpg
and then for the alt tag is going to be
lasagna
now before i refresh my page i want to
show you something
so in the same folder on my computer
with the my html file
i also have this lasagna.jpg
so as long as you have an image in the
same
folder as your html file you can just
link to it by putting the file name
right in here
and then when we upload our files to our
web server to host our website elsewhere
there's also going to be folders there
and we just have to make sure the images
are in the right folder here
so if i refresh my page we should see
a picture of lasagna one of the things
that cats love
in the description of this video i have
a link so you can download the picture
yourself
to put it into your website now we're
ready for another list
and this time it's going to be things
cats hate so this time instead of using
an unordered list
i'm going to put in an ordered list o l
and they're going to be three list items
the first item is flea treatment
second list item
is thunder and the third list item is
other cats oops li
other cats
let's see what that looks like so you
can see
the ordered list is numbered we have one
two three here of the things that cats
hate
i'm going to add another image right
below this
so image src
and this image is just called cats.jpeg
alt cats and just like before i have the
link to this
image in the description and this image
is already in the same folder
as my html file so if i refresh here
we see three cute cats which are things
that cats hate
well at least according to this website
on the internet
and as you know you can believe most
things on the internet
but cats don't just kind of hate these
things they really hate these things
so around the word hate i'm going to
surround it in a strong element
so i'll put strong and this
closing tag i'm going to cut this
closing tag and put it at the end of the
word hate
so now if i refresh this
you can see that this is bold here and
we're going to do something similar for
things
cats love i'm going to surround this in
an
e m tag to emphasize the word love
which is also the same as italicize so
if i save this and refresh we can see
things get
love and we have italicized here now
we're going to add another
common thing on websites which is a form
so we are going to add a form element
with an opening with an opening and
closing form tag
so right after this image i'm going to
put form
and then i'll put those on different
lines there will
indicate where to submit the form data
by adding an
action attribute on the form element
so it's going to look like this action
equals
slash submit cat
photo just like that
so now when you submit this form
we still have to add the submit button
but once we do when you click the submit
button
it will submit all the data to that url
now we're not going to actually create
that part of this website
this is just a basic html crash course
so we are not going to
do anything to handle this form data i'm
just going to show you how to create the
form
and you'll have to look for another
tutorial to learn how to
create the website that handles that
form submission
but the first thing in this form is
going to be a text
input element so right here
i'm going to put an input element
and i'm going to add a type and the type
is going to be text this is going to
make a
text box so if i save this and refresh
over here
we can see at the very end this text box
which i can
put all these any any text in this text
box down here
input elements do not need closing tags
we're going to add placeholder text to
this input
so this is going to be another attribute
place
place holder equals
cat photo url
so placeholder text you're just about to
see what that is but
it's this light gray text that appears
in the in this input box until you start
typing
as soon as you start typing it goes away
so that can indicate what's supposed to
go
into the input box under this
input element i'll add a submit button
so this is going to be a button element
and
it's going to have a type of submit
and this is this is going to have a
closing tag an opening and closing tag
and whatever text you put
in between the opening and closing tag
of a button is going to appear
on the button in this case we'll have it
say
submit
so if i save that and then i refresh
we can see that
there's a submit button right here now
if i click the submit button
remember we haven't implemented what
happens after you click the submit
button at that url
but that's how you would submit the data
clicking the button will send the data
from the form
to the url we specified in this action
attribute up here
let's make it so it's required to put in
a url before you can click the submit
button
that's pretty simple just in this input
to make that input required
i'm going to put an attribute required
most attributes have values but in this
case this does not have a value it's
just the attribute you just have to put
the word required it doesn't have to
equal anything
and now if i try to click the submit
button it says
please fill out this field you can use
radio buttons for questions where you
want the user to only give you one
answer out of multiple options here's
how you put a radio button
we're gonna put two radio buttons for an
indoor or outdoor
cat so right before this text box
i'm going to put an input element and
the type
this time is going to be radio
and then i'm just going to put indoor
and then i'll put another one input type
equals radio and this is going to be
out door if i save this and refresh
you can now see indoor and outdoor
oh right now if you click on it
they both just stay clicked so we are
going to eventually make it so when you
click on one it
unclicks the other so you can only have
one clicked at a time we also want to
make it so when you click on the text
it will make the button clicked to make
the
text also click the button we are going
to
nest everything within a label
element so i'm gonna put label
and then this closing tag i'm going to
cut that
and put it at the end here and you can
see it does
uh go to the next line and then i'll put
a label here
and then i'll cut this label and then
put it here and i'm going to save and
refresh
and now if i click the text outdoor
the radio button clicks if i click the
text endor the indoor button clicks
all related radio buttons should have
the same name attribute
to create a radio button group by
creating a radio group
selecting any single radio button will
automatically deselect the other buttons
within the same group
ensuring only one answer is provided by
the user
so i'm going to add the attribute indoor
outdoor
to each radio button so here it goes
right here i'm going to put
name indoor
outdoor and since i'm adding the same
one to every radio button i'm just going
to copy this
and i'm going to paste it
now if i refresh we have indoor
so when i click one the other one
deselects
next up i'm going to add an id attribute
to these buttons
an id attribute is used to identify
specific elements in other sections of
html css and javascript
so i'm going to add an id attribute set
to equal
indoor on the first radio input element
and id attribute set to equal outdoor
on the second radio input element so
i'm going to put the id and i'm going to
put as the first attribute
id equals
indoor and then
id equals outdoor
now one thing about these attributes is
that the order
doesn't matter so you can see on this
input
element there's three attributes there's
the id the type and the name
the order doesn't matter i could have
put name type id
or type id name the order doesn't matter
so
it's as long as you have a space in
between
each element or each attribute
it's going to all all work it's
considered best
practice to set a 4 attribute on the
label element
with a value that matches the value of
the id
element of the input element this allows
assisting technologies to create a
linked relationship
between the label and the child input
element so let me show you how you would
do that it's very simple
so for this label i'm going to put 4 and
it's going to be set to the same thing
as id which is indoor
so now we know that this label
is for this input because it has the
same
the four indoor oh the idor
indoor and we'll do the same thing right
down here
for out
door and erase this extra space so
yeah now we know this labels for this
input
i'm going to actually zoom out a little
bit on the code
so you can see more of what's going on
and it doesn't
it doesn't go to the next line as much
it doesn't wrap to the next line quite
as much
now none of this stuff we did actually
change what the web page
looks like but we are just about to
change something
you can see everything's on the same
line indoor outdoor
and this text this text box are all on
the same line
this is because line breaks in html have
no
impact on how a browser renders the page
to add a line break we're going to use
the br
tag for break so after
this first indoor one i'm going to put
br and i'm just going to copy this
and i'm going to put a br tag after each
of these
input elements and if i save that
refresh now you can see we have indoor
line break
outdoor line break and then the text box
and then there's another line break and
then the submit button
forms commonly use check boxes for
questions that may have more than one
answer
the code for a check box is very similar
to that of a radio button
so let me show you how to add a check
box we're going to add a check
box to check if a cat is loving or not
the personality of the chat the
personality of the cat
so here i'm going to put a label
just like the radio buttons and it's
going to be
four
loving
then i'm going to put the input element
and the input is going to have an id of
loving it's going to have a
type of
check box now to add some more
quotation marks here
and it's going to have a name
of personality
and then i'm just going to have to put
the word loving that's the word that's
going to appear
and you know let's just make this
consist we'll have this have a capital i
capital o okay let me refresh
and so we have indoor outdoor and we can
check
loving we can check it off and on let's
add a line break here
and then i'm going to add two more check
boxes
i'm just going to copy this check box
and then put two more in here now i'm
going to add some
line breaks in the html which will not
appear on the website
this is just to make it easier to see
the difference so we have
the radio buttons and we have the three
check boxes but we're going to put some
more personality traits
so this one is going to be lazy
some cats are lazy
and the next one is going to be
energetic energetic
now let's save this and refresh so now
we can see
the radio buttons we have these check
boxes we can check any number of
things and we have this text box we can
type in stuff here
to set a check box or radio button to be
checked by default
just add the word checked to the inside
of the input element
let me show you so we have this input
element right here
i'm just going to add the word checked
this is an attribute with no value
so we have checked there and then i'm
going to add checked here
if i can spell it there we go
refresh and now the indoors
automatically checked and
loving is automatically checked we're
getting close to being done with this
page
and i'm finally going to tell you about
one of the most
commonly used html elements of all
which is the div element also known as a
division element
it's a general purpose container for
other elements
one of the reasons is used so much is
because div elements
are often used to target with css
so you may want to style a whole section
of your web page
in one particular way and you can wrap
that all within a div element
and then you can use css to style that
div element
so we are going to put our lists
in a div element so i'm going to put an
opening div tag here
and then we have the closing div tag i'm
just going to cut this
i will actually zoom in on the code just
a little bit more and at the end of
things cast hate the end of this other
list
i'm going to put the closing div element
now
i'm going to indent everything in here
so you can see it's nested within the
div
so now we can see that inside this div
we have the things cats love and the
things
cats hate so the way that you would
often style
something like this with css is
to add a class attribute so i'm going to
put
class equals lists
class attributes are very commonly used
in html
specifically to style with css
so you can actually target all elements
with
the class of lists to make them have all
the same style
so maybe you went everything with the
class of lists like this to have a blue
background
or maybe you want to border around
everything or maybe you want
all the text to be a different color or
the text size be different
and you can in the css you can actually
target anything with the cl
anything inside a div with class
lists can have a certain style now we're
not going to go too far into that
because again this course is just about
html
you'll just have to look at a css course
to learn more about that
so now we're going to add a footer to
the web page
so we have the main section we here's
the closing main tag
i'm going to add a footer element now
the stuff inside a footer element is not
going to look any different on your page
this is mainly for screen readers and
seo purposes
so so the different sections of your web
page can be
identified and inside this footer we're
going to put a
paragraph tag it's going to say no
copyright
free code camp.org
so if i save this and refresh we can see
no copyright
freecodecamp.org and we can make this
into a real link
by putting a href equals
http colon hbs colon
slash free code
camp.org and then
i have to put this closing
a element the closing tag after the
freecodecamp.org
text here so if i save that and refresh
now we see this is now a link to
freecodecamp.org
and one other thing i want to show you
is that we could style
a lot of times the text in a footer is
smaller
now we could style that with css or we
can just put a small tag around
everything so let me put the closing
small tag
at the end here and save that if i
refresh
you can see now this text is a little
smaller
now let's go all the way back up to the
top of our html page
and we'll look at this html element
you'll notice that everything is inside
the html element
and inside this we are going to specify
the language of the website we want to
specify that this isn't
in english so i'll put lang
equals e e n for english
and i told you earlier that before the
body section of a website
you'll often have a head section of a
website
and so let's add that now
we got the head section the head section
is where
where metadata elements go stuff that's
not going to actually
show up in the content of your website
things such as link meta title style
so let me give you an example one of one
very common one is title
so i can create a title for this website
i'm going to put
cat photo app
i'm going to save this and see how here
it says index.html if i refresh
now it says cat photo app selling that
right from the title here
another thing that's common to use in
the head or to put in the head of a
website
is links to the external css file that's
going to be
used to style the page and the external
javascript
file that's going to be used to add
functionality to your page
and actually that's it this is a
complete html
page that we have created so
the next step is to update this to
our web hosting provider so we can
actually get this website on the
internet so other people can go to a url
to access this website
with hostinger you can deploy websites
directly
if you haven't learned tools like git
and linux yet this approach can save you
a lot of time and stress
start off by going to hostinger.com you
can click start now or just scroll down
and i would recommend if you're just
starting out just go with the cheapest
option the single
shared hosting and we'll just select
that
and then you just go through this
checkout process choosing the options
you want you'll probably
i would recommend the 12 months option
and then you just
put in your payment information i'm not
going to show
you the full account creation process
but after you get your account created
you'll get logged in
it's possible during the account
creation process you will have chosen
a domain name if you haven't there could
be a button on this screen
to create a domain name so if i scroll
down i can see
at the very bottom amazingcatpphotos.com
the domain name i got for our awesome
website that we just created
so to upload the photos to the website
we'll have to go to hosting i'm going to
go to this
menu up here and click hosting now
amazingcatphotos.com i'm going to manage
the hosting
okay now i just have to scroll down
to this file section and i go to file
manager
so now i'm going to make sure go into
the public html directory
and there may be something in this
folder if there is just delete it so you
have nothing in the folder
and now i'm just going to add my files i
can either drag them in
from a folder on my computer or i can
click upload files
and i'll just go and select the files so
here are the three files
index.html jpeg and lasagna.jpg and open
and upload
and it's as simple as that the website
should now work you may have to wait a
few hours if you just
created your website sometimes it can
take a few hours
from x from after you buy your website
until when you can actually go to the
url
and it will go to these files sometimes
it can even take a day
but once everything connects and
everything works then if you make any
changes it will happen
instantly just the first time when you
get it set up it could take a little
while
so let's try going to the website so
i'll go to www.amazingcatphotos.com
if you try and it doesn't work you may
have to hit you may have to add the www
dot at the beginning of the url so www
cat and this is the website we created
awesome hostinger made that super easy
okay you know the basics of html the
next step is to start learning css and
javascript
well thanks for watching